one more
we have started the live session as well
so if you
miss the meeting or you get disconnected
then you can join the meeting while the
youtube link as well
thank you we would be starting in just
two more minutes
i welcome you all to this free webinar
on machine learning for biomedical drug
discovery
this innovative summer online program
that discussed several key technologies
relevant to modern biomedical
data science research is designed to
modern biomedical data science
to introduce participants to the
application of data science to important
challenges
in clinical and pharmaceutical
applications using practical examples
that cover
genomic transcriptomic and structural
data
this collaborative program has brought
to you by pine biotech usa
faba academy india pharma toppers india
and pro biotechnica
india we now live in a world that is
recording data
every day the health care data
the health care data related to the
clinical trials electronically
medical records emrs genetic information
care management databases
billing internet research and social
media data is growing massively
and pose a challenge to the community of
students
scientists and researchers this
challenge is also an opportunity to
learn and discover from the vast amount
of information that is now available
publicly
after working for last several months
with a group of experts and industry
leaders we are now excited to bring this
unique opportunity
for students to learn and work on the
real data discovery pipeline for a
disease
or an indication to give a brief
introduction of the associations
pine biotech is a u.s based company that
provides resources solutions and
training for research and education
in biomedical informatics we have been
developing an innovative approach to
incorporate bioinformatics training
educational materials
and biomedical specializations for
universities
companies and top research labs
faba academy is a special wing under the
faba organization that focuses on
growing the students of the universities
nationwide
and make them future ready baba academy
prepares the students by providing skill
development and professional development
programs which gives them the confidence
to rule the world of pharma and biotech
industries
farmer toppers a pioneering institute
committed to provide
refined education to pharmacy aspirants
and training programs in bioinformatics
for marker vigilance
etc pro biotechnica research private
limited has a mission to equip and
empower every student and faculty with
the latest technology and tools to
create an
edge from others the company strongly
believes in serving society with quality
work so that the industry can get the
best out of its resources
and to make students industry ready
schrodinger prodigious physical based
computational platform integrates
differentiated solutions of predictive
modeling data analytics
and collaboration to enable rapid
exploration
of chemical space the platform powers
our own drug discovery efforts from
target identification
to hit discovery to lead optimization
it also drives our research
collaborations to develop novel
medicines for critical public health
needs
now let me introduce you to our
scientists from
dr prajwal dandikal dr prajwal nandhikar
received his masters
and phd from the national institute of
pharmaceutical education and research
neighbor mahali in 2010 and 2015
respectively he is a recipient of the
prestigious dad fellowship
to perform research at hidelberg
university
dr pritish bhatt he is currently working
as a senior scientist at schrodinger
bangalore
his doctoral research involves the
identification of inhibitors
for various enzyme targets of
mycobacterium using different
computational modeling approaches
at birla institute of technology and
science bits pilani
mr vinod devraji he's a senior scientist
at schrodinger working with computer
aided drug discovery research for nine
years
he completed his m pharma with madras
medical college of pharmacy
he has research experience in topics
such as computer aided drug designing
dna intergalations organometallic
compounds and biologics
personally he is holding 30 research
publications
in repetitive international publication
groups for his credit
dr kaushik kasawajala is currently
working as a senior scientist i
at schrodinger at bangalore he received
his phd in chemistry in 2020
from stony brook university new york usa
he holds day eight publications to date
with two more in preparation
his work has been cited more than 3500
times
his research interests include
developing enhanced sampling methods and
force fields for biomolecular
simulations
and designing antibodies and drug
molecules
mr k sure v soca solutions
architect provides technical supports to
users
the program will leverage our top rated
online tutorials
using the error tbio info portal with
smart tracking of
activity and curated data sets designed
for a great learning experience
in this program we will combine online
sessions
self-guided study materials and
practical assignments for an immersive
experience that has been proven to be
effective
in our well-known and respected or mixed
logic programs
we will learn important concepts within
biomedical research infectious diseases
cancer research and learn about the
immunology of infection molecular
disease markers and stages
and how these diseases can be diagnosed
and treated using machine learning
approaches
for different parts of the sessions we
will leverage or mix logic resources
that you can use to learn about machine
learning
asynchronous coursework with theoretical
material
quizzes and practical assignments are
cloud-based analytical server where you
can analyze
large genomic data and visualize results
the omixlogic code playground where you
can practice
coding in r and python as well as
repository of project
example so let's start
by signing up to learn dot omics logic
this educational portal will help you
get started with your bioinformatics
journey
now i request you all to please go to
the server omixlogic.com
you can type in omixlogic.com
now those who are already signed up into
this server
they may sit back and those who are not
signed up i request
them to please sign up yourself in this
learn.ohmixlogic.com portal
once you are done please send a yes in
the chat box so that we can proceed
further
thank you so much dr harpreet dr
harpreet has shared the link of the
portal learn.ormixlogic
please sign up so that we know that you
are signed up please send a yes
i can see a lot many responses
let's wait for two more minutes for
others to sign up as well
signing up on this portal would help you
get the access
of all the courses and also let you know
about our upcoming programs and
trainings and you can easily register
yourself here for the courses
or the trainings
those who have signed up and those who
have
not can take two more minutes to do so
yes i'll shortly share the slack channel
link so that you can join
for others we also have a slack channel
where we communicate directly
and tell about all our upcoming courses
and trainings
i will share the link soon
so throughout the course you will be
given the directions to access the t
bioinfo platform for bioinformatics
processing and analysis of
transcriptomics data
the platform includes demo pipelines as
well as data management and analysis
cloud infrastructure
to run bioinformatics pipelines
different stages of analysis
are performed in different sections to
this multi-omics
platform and in each course you will
load
transform and visualize data in r
and in python now i would like to
invite our ceo ilya brodsky to discuss
more about the program on machine
learning for biomedical drug discovery
and also share the details of the
sessions over to you india thank you so
much
thank you very much
and welcome everybody to this webinar so
i will just kind of briefly introduce
some of the topics
uh to give you a background on what we
will be offering
during the data science program starting
on june 14th
and uh to briefly introduce you on my
part of this
presentation i want to give you a little
bit of a background about pine biotech
what we do
and how did we arrive at the omixlogic
portal idea
so that you will be oriented in the
program itself
and think about some of the applications
of data science and biomedical research
so pine biotech is a technology transfer
company
originally the company was formed
to commercialize research coming out of
the tower bioinformatics research center
at the university of haifa
and our team has been working for about
a couple of years to
make sure that the same tools that are
used in many
cutting edge research projects and
biomedical
data analysis are being available and
come with training for students
researchers
and clinicians and so the program that
we developed has been
tested and piloted in many different
settings including the louisiana
biomedical research network
uh different programs like georgetown
university systems medicine
as well as universities around the world
and so as a result
we have received a lot of feedback that
we've incorporated
into the way that the training program
has been structured
but our company doesn't just focus on
training itself
and so as a part of
various different research projects and
collaborations
we have been privileged to work on a
number of research application
development
for different areas that i will be
actually talking about
in just a few minutes one of these has
to do with the integration
of omics data in a variety of big data
research projects
as you can see here this is integration
of
different types of data phenotypic data
and data about omics
analysis we've worked on a number of
collaborations for biomarker discovery
in real world evidence collection and
clinical trial projects
as well as projects for small molecule
screening and
this hit to lead optimization
from libraries of small molecules
and so as a result of this kind of
research experience we really developed
this kind of a data science
program that is intended to give an
opportunity for
students that come from high school
undergraduate as well as postgraduate
level
teachers and faculty at high schools
colleges and universities as well as
researchers like biologists and
clinicians at research labs and
biotechnology companies
an opportunity to master tools and
skills
that are required for effective
data-driven
research projects and so to speak a
little bit more about the way that this
program is organized i want to give you
a background
on what omixlogic as a training portal
really
is so now that you've all signed up
to the omixlogic portal let me introduce
what the programs courses and different
training resources that we have
how are they organized and what's the
difference between them
so the goal of our mixed logic programs
is to provide training in bioinformatics
and i'll talk a little bit about the
relationship between bioinformatics and
data science
in a little bit and the important part
of it
is to enable independent research guided
by mentors and peer examples so it's
more than just
a collection of courses it's also a
community and this community is
shared has a shared passion for
data-driven research
and an appreciation of citizen science
and so what's important here is that
this is a community where you can
kind of get to know other people you can
collaborate with other people on
research projects
and a critical part of that is
essentially training
and one of the challenges that we see is
that
many people from different backgrounds
have to
apply different types of data science
skills
to develop independent research projects
using latest technology in life and data
sciences
and so one of the programs that we've
developed as a result of this
kind of vision for this omnicology
community is
a program on onyx logic data science
and this kind of a program combines
resources online asynchronously
and in a blended fashion to
empower different types of people with
different backgrounds
to learn about statistical analysis and
machine learning experimental design and
technical variation
that is to found in exploratory data
analysis as well as to apply
data mining tools for meaningful for
finding meaningful patterns and
associations
and study complex biological systems
using big data
so this program on data science combines
a number of different important aspects
including
different types of omics data steps for
exploratory data analysis and
processing data analysis for big data
integration and mining
and the application of these different
tools
to different types of research questions
so
today's webinar is going to focus on a
number of these aspects which
we will do an introduction to data
science and bioinformatics so what's the
relationship between data science and
bioinformatics
and a little overview of data processing
cleaning and exploration how to do that
and what are some of the tools that we
will cover in this program
the application of data science in
biomedicine
introduction to machine learning
algorithms for next generation
sequencing data
the application of data mining and
integration for
multi-omics or x-omics integration and
then i will pass it on to our next
speaker to talk about deep learning
natural language processing and image
analysis and how those
are important in this domain of
biomedical data
analysis so let me first start by
speaking about the relationship between
data science and
bioinformatics so what is data science
really
data science is data storage
organization
retrieval including application of
different data formats
biological specialization right if we
talk about
the domain where we apply data science
in the context of biomedical data
science
right this includes biological research
uh but it could include
many other different domains right and
so here
what we all can appreciate is
the similarity between data science and
bioinformatics because
all the same different aspects of data
science
if they are exclusively applied to
biological data
now we can call that bioinformatics and
so when you think about bioinformatics
really
that talks about different types of
information
technologies applied to biological or
biomedical research
and so one of the differences where we
see the importance of these kinds of
skills
in information management in statistical
analysis and machine learning
is the specific application
of these methods to
major impactful questions in biomedical
data
and so two main areas that i want to
focus on today
are drug discovery and clinical trials
because i think that in both of these
areas
there's a major change or a paradigm
shift that is going
on and many of you are probably aware of
these
transformations but they really require
this change in thinking about the way
data
is used for these two problems so what
is the challenge in drug discovery
one of the major challenges in drug
discovery is the time
how much time does it take to get from
a number of potentially active compounds
to a compound that could actually be
brought to market
through the different stages of
commercialization of that compound and
that goes through
stages of research and discovery where
multiple compounds are analyzed and
several are selected to then hip to lead
optimization
and then through several stages of
clinical trials
and so the clinical trials area is the
second
major area where this transformation is
quite obvious
in clinical trials you have to design
a specific process by which that
compound
that is not toxic and is efficacious
can go through several stages of
validation and that requires selection
of the right types of candidate patients
the right kinds of indicators and the
right kind of validation for
a certain level of efficacy for those to
proceed
from stage one to stage three and then
to be observed in post-market
surveillance to understand
how other types of patients are
responding to this type of treatment
so these two areas are very important in
the area of data science for biomedical
data
and those are some of the things that we
will focus on in
this program now importantly i think
there's
a huge opportunity in regards to this
kind of
big data because a lot of this type of
data is actually available
on publicly available repositories and
not only is it available we
know that since this pandemic the amount
of data is actually
growing and so this accelerated pace
of availability of big data that is now
accessible to anyone who is interested
in
asking research questions about this
type of data
provides us also with an opportunity to
develop these kinds of training programs
where instead of giving you test
examples we can actually
leverage some of these real life project
examples
from the research and clinical areas to
provide you with
an immersive experience where you can
apply specific types of data science
tools and methods to ask questions about
these kinds of data sets
so the first challenge having this kind
of availability of data the first
challenge that i
see is the challenge of data structures
how to clean process and normalize
the huge variety of data types
that is available and these include
imaging data
streaming data like emr clinical data
on mix data chemical data phenotypic
data
all have to be prepared so that they are
structured and available
for the layer of analytics that we would
like to apply
in a meaningful way to these types of
data sets and potentially
even integrate them to find associations
between
the phenotypic data and the different
types of omnics data that are available
and so one of the things that our
company has been focused on
is making the omnics data simplified
democratized and more clearly understood
by
the millions of researchers that are out
there trying to
understand the molecular drivers of
disease
as well as molecular indicators of
treatment efficacy
and so the first challenge in omics data
that i see
is the variability of data types and
what do they actually represent so
since they provide a very detailed view
of molecular changes and activities
inside the cell we're talking at a
subcellular precision
that comes with a lot of challenges and
so what are these omics data types
one type of omics is phenomics where we
can look at
cell morphology and characterize
different cell shapes
and activities we can look at genomic
data which is essentially variation
at the dna code we can look at
epigenomic data which essentially tells
us about
sub genomic regulation so regulation
that is not inside the dna code itself
but provides a
layer of modification like data sets
like
whole genome by sulfide sequencing and
chromatin immunoprecipitation where we
can understand
different types of variations
transcriptomic data
the result of expression
of mrna and downstream modification of
that
mrna and so as you can see these data
sets
are very different they're different
because
they describe these different aspects of
the same
biological phenomena but using different
technologies
and so the first part of this program we
will do
a little overview of how to process
and structure such data so that it is
ready for integration and so here we
will
look at several different examples of
genomic data like whole exome sequencing
and whole genome sequencing
epigenome genomic data like dna
methylation and gypsy
transcriptomic data analysis for single
cell
and bulk rna sequencing as well as
proteomic and metabolomic data
so all of them coming from the
biological
material and being processed into a
structured
data set and so now once the data set
is structured now we enter the domain of
data science and in this domain of data
science now we can
operate with the same statistical
data exploration and classification
methods
that allow us to ask questions about
relationships
of these different and distinct data
types
that describe different types of
biological phenomena
but also different types of biomedical
applications
about recruitment of patients for
clinical trials
about what drives disease progression
and about what kinds of treatment
targets are there available
to be able to intervene in a specific
malignant process
and so as an example we can take a look
at
how this is changing the way we can
treat patients
ultimately when we generate new data
instead of coming as a new set of data
we essentially see that as an integrated
data set combined with other existing
samples that allow us to ask questions
about
population similar patients patients
that have
benefited from different types of
treatments and
the features that define those patients
or different types of
markers that we could rely on to
optimize
future treatment so omics logic
is essentially a complete road map
for data science in our application to
biomedical research data
that we'll talk about finding data sets
exploring and visualizing those data
sets
understanding different types of
research methodologies
and gain insight and understanding
looking
at some of those questions that are
being asked by
top medical journals and research
studies that we can find in the public
domain
so let's take a look a little bit at
what the omixlogic portal will show you
as you consider joining this upcoming
program
so once you have registered on this
portal
the omixlogic portal you will see here a
number of different resources that we
will leverage
in this upcoming program and this
includes
different research project examples
processing tools for big data analysis
that you will
gain access to throughout our server
portal which is a server for big data
analysis
different coding exercises that will
allow you to take
process data perform data exploration
data visualization and analysis and
looking at different kind of case
studies that
show how these different methods are
applied to different types of
research questions so that we can answer
them in a data-driven way
so first of all there are many different
applications
including oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience and agriculture and
in each one of these categories we will
take examples of
projects where you can understand the
specifics
of the data that is being generated and
the specific
questions that are being asked the first
challenge that we will overcome is the
challenge of big
data and there we will utilize the
user-friendly
and logical user pipeline builder
that will allow us to do sequence
alignment
analysis of gene expression data or even
analysis of the microbiome
to structure that data and prepared for
analysis
then we will proceed to look at
different types of
coding languages like python and
r to understand how to load that data
explore and analyze that data in a
meaningful way
so let me give you an example of what
that looks like
if you go right here to the courses tab
you will find here a number of examples
for what i am describing here so you can
see
different types of projects that we will
give you access to
and you will see some examples of the
coursework
that you could take a look at one when
you subscribe to the program
so let's take a look at some of these
examples by looking
at this course called introduction to
data science in r
and i will paste this link in the chat
okay so here once you have reached this
page you will see some
examples of different lessons that we
will go through
including how to load data and check for
different types of variables uh how to
visualize data using
basic and more advanced methods how to
explore data
using tools like principal component
analysis and
visualization different statistical
relationships
how to perform kind of specific methods
like differential gene expression
clustering k-means and hierarchical
clustering some examples of
unsupervised machine learning how to
perform classification with random
forest
and other types of methods and all the
way to
an understanding of how different
statistical tests can help us extract
meaningful features from our data and
interpret them in a biological way
so you will find these different
examples these are courses that are free
that you can try for free even before
you join the program
and then some of the more advanced
methods that are highlighted here with
a star you can use once you either
get an asynchronous subscription which
is very affordable
or proceeding to look at some of our
programs
so the programs that we offer this is an
example of a program
where you will be guided by mentors that
are experienced
in a particular domain and explain
specifics of how this data is applied to
different examples
so the benefit of joining a program is
not only gaining access to the different
resources that you are seeing here on
the screen
but also being able to interact with the
mentor and the participants of the full
program
and once you interact with them to be
able to
schedule a a session with that mentor
to have one-on-one mentoring with that
person
also being able to interact with other
participants of the program
by joining the slack
channel and so here you will see
a program overview so uh
this is a link to the specific program
that we are starting on june 14th so you
can see right here
starting on june 14th uh you can see a
little overview of this program right
here in the video
here are the different sessions that
mohit will describe
in just a few minutes and then as you
scroll down you see some of the
access that will be provided as a part
of this
program training so you will combine
asynchronous materials
and in-person sessions that are
described there
now many of you are probably wondering
what are the different options and how
to complete your registration
and so for that i want to make sure that
we can
answer all of the questions in the next
maybe 30 or 45 minutes of this webinar
and explain anything that you will need
to know
to gain the most benefit out of this
program
but before we do and before i pass on
uh my part of the session to uh the next
speaker
so if you could uh start the poll
um so that we get we can get to know
some of the participants
in this webinar today
yes sure area uh thank you so much so
i've just started the poll
i've got three questions for you all and
i would
want you to answer these so we can know
you better
the first question is what is your
educational background
graduation post graduation phd or post
talk
and my second question is what are your
research interests
and the third one is what is the reason
you are entrusted to attend the
training this poll would be on
for more two minutes and i request you
all to please answer the questions
thank you
okay thank you very much now all of you
that
are already that have already answered
this
question for the this poll um i want to
invite
many of you that are interested in
uh learning some of these tools
many of you are interested in many
different aspects of the program
including learning how to code
gaining advanced understanding of
machine learning and deep learning
receive a certificate mentorship
and all of the above so i see that the
majority right now
all of the above
okay and so before i answer some of the
questions in the chat which i will do in
just a few minutes
for those of you that have completed the
poll
i want to connect with all of you in a
professional way
on uh social media and so what i would
like
to ask is that all of you join our
group on linkedin which is
a group where you can find a lot of the
mentors that we have as well as a lot of
the
participants of previous programs so if
you could
please join uh this group called
uh omex logic
that will allow you to see some of the
information
that we will have about upcoming
sessions
uh opportunities to join different types
of
research fellowships and internships
that are available over the summer
and also interact with professionals
that will be
mentoring this program and potentially
you could benefit from
getting to know in the course of the
next program so
uh a great resource that is beyond the
training obviously free
and if i could ask sonalika that you
also post the link to the facebook group
as well
okay so let me now uh go
through some of the questions that are
in the chat and make sure that i
answer those as well so i see a lot of
questions here about certification and
different types of courses so
i will leave that for the later part of
today's webinar uh dr mohit mizunder at
the end of the webinar will
explain uh some of those things and how
to join how to register
what are the different sessions and how
to get certification
you will get the certificate and this
certificate will be partly automated
through our
system where we track all of the
activity and partly will be
also approved by the mentors that will
be guiding this program
for those that are coming from computer
science background
this is a very interesting question so i
want to just pause right there
so it's very important that many of
these methods in data science
are widely accessible through many
different tutorials and many different
systems online and so
that is perfectly fine if you're already
a data scientist
or an engineer the question becomes how
do you apply these skills effectively
to an area of biomedical discovery
including the applications to
pharmaceutical and biotechnology
companies
or clinical diagnostics and clinical
research
and so the main answer to that question
is that this
whole curriculum is very project driven
so what we will do is we will introduce
you to the different data types but also
experimental design and the questions
that are being asked in the research
papers that we leverage
so that you can actually apply the
methods that you probably already know
but to the different data types and the
different
questions that are being asked maybe in
a domain that you're not so familiar
with
already so vm dev hopefully
this answers your question right there
um subarus is asking if i could explain
normalization
in a few sentences so definitely
normalization
is a critical part of preparing your
data for analysis
because many times when you deal with
different
laboratories different types of settings
data that is being generated in the
different settings
is affected by many technical variables
that we don't have any control over
so if you think about distance if i
measure
distance in the us in india or in china
it's going to be the exact same distance
but if i measure
gene expression that gene expression is
going to be subject to the technical
things that i have in my lab the way i
collected the biological sample
the timing of my analysis and so many
other technical things and so to be able
to compare
gene expression in the us in india and
china
i won't have to normalize them and there
are several factors that you need to
keep in mind
when you perform this normalization at
different stages
of the data science kind of inter
process right so the process of dealing
with that data
okay so about the timing of the program
so the timing of the program right now
is going to
start on june 14th as is mentioned right
here
you can see the detailed schedule also
on this link as well
and so i will just once again post this
link right here
um let's see uh so
what other questions so i am a
bioinformatics postgraduate
and want to start my career as a
bioinformatics analyst or assignment
it's perfect
so shavita having a bioinformatics
background is a perfect opportunity to
apply yourself
to different types of industry jobs and
that's one of the reasons why we also
recommend joining the program with these
mentors
who have that academic and industry
background
and i'm sure that they will mention that
in their part of the presentation
uh what are the skills recruiters are
searching to shortlist candidates for
hiring
again perfect question i recommend also
looking
at the linkedin group that we introduced
today
that's where we post a lot of these
opportunities for
industry internships research
fellowships and also jobs and so
there you will see some of those
questions answered as well
for those that are from a botany
background uh sayida
i think that's a perfect background
because you're already versed in
biological data you know
what the data coming from different
types of experiments
looks like now you need to understand
how it differs
when you talk about biomedical
applications and what are the elements
of data science that you need to
master so that you can apply yourself
effectively in these new
methods and applications
will this course cover the
interpretation and analysis of
multinomics data
so for that reason let me briefly show
you
some of the things that we will cover
and these are related to data processing
analysis and integration so what we
specialize in
is the analysis of omnics data and
the logic behind that analysis so how do
you actually
take a look at a specific data type and
understand the logic of how it is
prepared
and what are some of the questions that
you can ask about now in the context of
this platform that i'm showing
on my screen which is what we will use
for some of the sessions in the
beginning of the program
you will see here multi-ohmics
integration and so for multi-homicide
integration
we will take a look at several different
methods
that are based on either unsupervised or
supervised integration
so that we can understand relationship
between features
coming from different audience data
types and their relationships so we will
cover that in one of the sessions
it will not be necessarily the exclusive
focus of the program but we will
definitely
look at that as well okay
so thank you everybody for in uh for the
questions i hope that i was
uh able to answer some of those
questions maybe not all of them
if you are interested to ask me more
questions about this
or to ask our team about different
programs please stay until the end of
the webinar where
many of these questions will be answered
and you can also submit your question
right here in the chat box
and later after the webinar our team
will be able to answer those as well
so now let me pass it on to the next
speaker i'll briefly introduce him here
uh uh dr uh suggest
so um dr sujit
tango tanga de
sorry if i mispronounce your name is a
founder of pharma toppers and co-founder
of an iit company called
octam pbt and
currently he is a lead data scientist on
computer vision projects at era matrix
he served in multiple positions in many
companies before like persistent systems
accelera
hexaware and others and played a crucial
role in applying artificial
intelligence in the drug discovery field
he obtained his phd
in pharmacoinformatics from national
institute of pharmaceutical education
and research
in mahali and he published several
research papers and peer-reviewed
journals and developed industry
both softwares in the field of chemo
informatics and bioinformatics in his
industry and
academic tenure he has been using his
programming skills
to solve biological and chemical
problems for a long time
and now he is joining this program as a
mentor and he will be taking
some of the topics including the
applications of data science
in pharmaceutical and biotechnology
companies machine learning and deep
learning
natural language processing as well as
chemo informatics
so let me pass it on to doctors
thank you ilya for the nice introduction
and thank you for
explaining about the project and all
about the program
everything about thank you
so uh sonalika could you please make me
host so that i can share my screen
yes
thank you so much
hope my screen is visible to everyone
yes sir it's visible
thank you yeah as uh said uh this is dr
sujit sangarpaliwa
i'm a founder of former toppers and
co-founder of private limited i did my
phd from knifer
in the area of human informatics and
drug discovery wherein i applied several
machine learning and deep learning
technologies to solve
chemical and biological problems during
my phd time
so being a part of this course as an
industry expert i'll
mostly deals with the deep learning
machine learning
all those algorithms the math the
mathematic behind
those algorithms natural language
processing i'll explain you about what
exactly the natural language processing
is
this might be a very new terminology for
many of you
computer vision it is it is all based on
the image analysis
image processing and all the stuff and
the ai you might have seen
you might have heard about it it's a a
artificial intelligence is actually a
brain of any robot or
any intelligence system so uh mostly
deep learning natural language
processing machine learning computer
vision is all
actually part of a or a data science
so into this course uh initially we have
uh on a 14th of june that could be a
first session wherein we will deal with
the
various machine learning algorithm what
exactly machine learning is
uh what are those algorithms for
emotional learning and the
little bit math behind those algorithm
instead of only learning a theoretical
part of
machine learning will also go deeper
somewhat deeper
for the the mathematics which is
involved in machine learning as well
as as well as in a deep learning so nlp
is actually stands for natural language
processing natural language processing
actually deals with the data called
textual data mostly
so let's say you have a set of
genes you have a smile structures in a
structure of a molecule in a smiles
format or if you have
protein protein sequences everything can
be deal with
natural language processing technology
called nlp
so i'll help you out how we can process
those data using nlp technology
as of now very few industries in india
or abroad they are using
nlp technologies for gene or protein
data
but yes we in this course will explore
that part as well
on a computer vision site uh we we will
deal with the several images of a drug
molecules wherein
based on images of a drug molecule we
could able to find out the toxicity
or a biological property of a molecule
so in this course i'll
i'll highlight and i'll share the code
which can help you guys to
work on image data to find out the many
several biological properties
of a molecule on a 16th of june we will
go somewhat deeper at the mathematics
behind those
neural networks uh when i talk when i
say deep deep learning deep learning is
actually a
they are a neural networks uh if if any
neural network contains more than
two more than one or more than two
hidden layers they are called actually a
deep neural networks so we will go
behind
we'll go somewhat mathematics how to
tweak those
networks how we can what are those input
parameters how we can define the output
parameters how we can build the network
will go everything about it and also
we'll go somewhat
somewhat mathematics behind the natural
language processing
what are the word corpora says how how
we can use word embeddings
i mean how we can convert those words
into a numbers as
you know computer can only understand
the numbers the computer doesn't know
whether it is a protein or a drug
molecule or a gene or a
uh or any any dna sequence computer
doesn't understand but computer
only understand the language of the
numbers or is being zero and one
so in this course we will help you out
and we will teach you will train you on
how we can convert those text i mean the
smiles notation or
protein sequence or a gene sequence into
the numbers and how we can process those
numbers using
natural language processing uh in this
nlp part we will also learn some
some little bit about uh what are word
embeddings tfid factorizer and count
vectorizers uh where
these are the method to convert uh text
into a number
and uh another algorithm called
convolutional neural network in this
in in this is called a cnn in this
algorithm we will
will walk you through how we can build a
cnn model what are the parameters
involved in cnn model
how we can read those images image data
and how we can
pull out those pull out features from
those images and how we can use those
features for
uh cnn model builder development and how
we can use this
model for the further prediction of our
either of any of the biological property
of a molecule or a protein
in a next session uh we will share some
of the codes with you
this this session could be a completely
of a practical session
wherein we'll share some python program
by the time you will learn most of the
you will get a hands-on on a python and
r as well
and also we will share some python
programs with you and we'll ask you to
write some python program
to let's say to calculate a biological
properties of a molecule or to find out
the
toxicity of a molecule or a protein
so we will also will help you to uh
write a code for several other
biological properties of molecule and
will have we have several case studies
with us so and also we will share those
case studies with you
and also will help you to solve some
minor bugs or a problem
uh those are if you if you get some uh
some
bugs associated with that code so these
are the three live sessions i
uh uh which which are on 12th 16th and
uh sorry 14th 16th and 18th of june
uh for other session i would like mohit
to talk on
about machine learning in data science
also machine learning in biomedical data
science
mohit over to you
thank you sujeeth for the wonderful
overview
let me share my screen
hello everyone uh am i audible
sonica
okay thank you hello everyone my name is
mohit mazumdar and i'm one of the
co-mentor
and project guide for the students or
cohorts
who are interested in working on their
own biomedical project
so this about this program and the
sessions uh as you have already heard
from
dr sujeeth let me explain the next few
uh the next sections of the program so
the purpose of this is to
understand about biomedical data science
so data science has the potential as you
as you know has the potential to uh to
be to be impactful in pharma and
other uh industries such as
uh application of data science in
clinical trials and also
you know it helps in cutting down the
cost and all of that so in this
entire program we will be learning about
the roles
of machine learning and to interpret and
analyze biomedical data
so the sessions as you have already gone
through the first three sessions
uh the next section will be
will be taken up by dr harpreet bar who
is
an expert in machine learning techniques
and has several publications
applying data science techniques in
different types of omics data
so in this program you will be learning
about how to
load explore visualize analyze
biomedical data using
big data analytical tools and coding in
r and python so the session after that
so after the after the first three
sessions so this would be the fourth
session
and here you will learn about the nts
data types some of the examples of
continuous
continuous data which is the gene
expression data
and then examples of categorical data
which is like the clinical
and the drug response data so in this
session you will be introduced to
complex datasets
and need and then we will be
helping you understand how to prepare
and analyze the data set
uh correctly and to do some
exploratory statistical analysis
so in the next session which will be the
fifth session
on 23rd june we will use supervised
machine learning algorithms
such as principal component analysis
hierarchical
and k-mean clustering to find groups
and then to find patterns and similarity
in large data sets
and the next session which will be the
sixth session uh after learning about
the unsupervised machine learning
methods
we will be in this session we will be
learning about training and test data
sets
and how we can apply classification
algorithms such as decision tree
random forest super support vector
machine
after the session once we have had the
introduction
and understanding about different
techniques and
learn to apply different algorithms
using the tbionfo platform
in the next session which will be the
seventh session
we will be discussing and we will be
guiding participants
to develop independent biomedical data
science projects
and as i was telling you about this that
in this
session we will be understanding about
the the different technologies that were
applied in a project
and how to do the data integration when
we are considering multiple data sets
so after learning about this part uh the
sessions
starting from 30th june till 7th july
will focus on coding in python nr
and performing different machine
learning algorithms
on project or example data sets that we
will be sharing
with all the participants using our
slack channels or emails
and whatever all the other resources so
in addition to the sessions the
participants will be able to learn by
completing the associated tutorials on
the omixlogic portal that you saw
so in the next session we will be
performing clustering on different
biomedical datasets and understand what
it
means in the context of a research
so after this in the session on 5th july
we will learn about classification and
understanding the effectiveness and to
differentiate the results
that you obtain from different machine
learning algorithms
so after this we will we will dive deep
into the model accuracy and validation
and use
for this we will use examples of
clinical
and uh ngs data
and in the 12th session which is the pen
ultimate
session studio schedule session we will
discuss the real world applications of
machine learning
and we will also go through the
understanding
of how artificial intelligence can
make a difference in decision making
so in the last session last schedule
session
we will review the project proposals and
we will provide
feedback from industry experts on the
project proposals
and what would be the next steps so this
session will be about planning your
bioinformatics analysis
literature review compiling your primary
data sets developing a research plan
and methodology performing exploratory
analysis
data processing and preparation
statistical analysis biological
interpretation and validation
i know it sounds a lot but these are the
steps that you need to go through
when you go through or design a
biomedical project
which would be one of the objectives of
this program and
this is what we have prepared for uh you
to
go through the biomedical data science
program
but along with this program as a part of
this entire
initiative uh the summer initiative we
will be also doing the
kami informatics program which will be
going along
parallelly so before i we talk more
about how you can register
for the data science program i'll also
tell you a little bit about the cameo
informatics program
and then i'll pass it on to uh mr malika
to
to tell you more about how you can
register for either one of the program
or
for both the program if you are also
interested in key informatics and
the data science involved in that
chemical space
so the the program which will run
subsequently and like it will be running
alongside the data science program
so the sessions are scheduled on
different different dates
so the sessions does not align so so the
students who are opting for both the
program can take it
as well so this program uh is designed
to address
uh the challenges associated with
understanding
modeling uh screening and applying kami
informative strategies
to improve drug discovery results and in
if this program will be starting on 15
june and
it will be available and it will be the
sessions will be
scheduled till 22 july 2021
so in this program we also have a
two-day complete workshop this is all
day workshop
so in this workshop participants will
get practical experience and
in-person guidance to use the tools that
are offered by stradenger
so you will learn about the maestro gui
and
how to do organic molecules molecule
sketching
that will be very useful in your own uh
designing the molecule
project if you're if you are interested
and also like screening
for heat identification and finding
therapeutic therapeutic targets and all
of that
it will be available at session third
and session fourth
it's planned for the weekend uh so
we will have several sessions where we
will be going through practical hands-on
in this one
so you'll learn about docking then
you'll learn about it to lead
modification using software
and then there's a session on free
energy perturbation using the molecular
dynamics simulation data that will be
covered in the second day of the
workshop
so these are some of the opportunities
that are upcoming
so in all we are trying to help you
develop
understanding about different types of
data set and how data science plays a
role in it
so there is an important sessions that
will be available
to those who join join the programs that
we are offering right now
as a part of summer programs so data
science and its application in clinical
trials and clinical research
so you'll be getting all of that
and learning all uh application of ain
healthcare
using uh the resources that will be
available for you
in june and which will uh with the
entire training will be
available for one month and also the
access to scrotinger software license
and also access to the t-band for server
license
so a very
interesting aspect for a researcher
to go through these tools and to develop
projects and
show this to uh in our upcoming
symposium in august and get an
opportunity to win prizes
and also to participate and get feedback
from international panel of experts so
all of that is coming up
and for you to start that journey now
i'll just pass it on to sunaliga
to talk about and get you registered
thank you all and if there are any
questions
i'll be looking at it and i'll be
answering them in the chat or
throughout the session thank you
thank you so much dr mohit
so let me take you through the
registration process
so first of all we have this
pre-registration page over here
i would be sharing the links with you
here
so uh just to learn about the program
more in detail so we had four phases we
are done with
two of them already that was on genomics
and transcriptomics and now we are
starting with the fourth phase that
that is on machine learning and then we
have chemo informatics as well
so to know more about the program and to
pre-register yourself you can refer this
link over here
and this is the pre-registration form
you can fill it out
we'll get your entries and then we'll
get back to you
once we receive your pre-registration
form
to register yourself directly you can
simply go to the machine learning for
biomedical
drug discovery page over here
and start your application
i'll just share the page link so just
start with the application
and you will get to know the different
levels we have for this program
these levels are different based on the
provisions you would get
the access and the mentorship guidance
you would get
and once you get started with the
application you can simply choose the
option you would like to proceed with
select the option and proceed further
and also
many are times people want to know more
detail of these sessions so elia has
already told you that you could get the
session details
over here as well on which day what
topics would be covered
and to get the details on the chemo
informatics program
i'm showing you i'm again sharing this
link here with you
so i had a common doubt people were
asking me what is the registration link
for chemo informatics
so this is the chem informatics
page and then you have to have the
machine learning page but
for all the programs our
pre-registration form is does the same
right so you can simply go ahead and
proceed your application from these
pages
now if you have any doubts please let me
know in the comment section itself so we
can take it here
and to know more about the chem
informatics program
we would actually be conducting a
webinar on third
june to talk more about chem informatics
in detail
and to discuss each and every session
topics which would be covered in the
program
over there so i'll be sharing the link
of that particular
session as well with you and you guys
also can get yourself registered for
both the programs
at just one time by paying for both
of them at one single time and those who
have
not yet followed us on the social can do
so by following us on the
uh linkedin page over here omixlogic now
i'm asking you this
just because i want you all to stay
updated with all these sessions and
webinars we have
so that you don't miss out the chance of
your research interest
training and then we have our facebook
page
so i've shared the link but i'll be
sharing it once again
registration can be paid by invoice yes
anurak it can be paid by invoice as well
you can mail me at marketing at the rate
pine for any of the queries you have
which you are not able to ask right now
maybe
and also if you face any issues at any
particular step you can
mail me and i would be there to help you
out and
you if you want me to generate an
invoice
for you please maybe that as well you'll
get the invoice then and there
and also we uh we was remaining live for
this
session we had today so the recording is
here if
any one of you missed out on the
important
point you can refer the video here and
also i would be sharing the recording
with you as well if you guys have any
doubt please ask in the comment section
or as uh we can end the session
yes i would be sharing the workshop
recordings as well after each and every
session
and those recordings would be
downloadable and during this
so being a part of the training program
would
uh get you the access of our uh portal
you would be able to go through the
training properly you would get the
access of a t
by info server as well that would be
for the whole length of the program that
is one month
and you would also get the mentorship so
during the program whatever doubts you
face
your mentor would be there to help you
out
okay okay so chitra i'll send in the
group itself
so chitra are you already a research
fellow or
are you a member of the fine itself
which group are you talking about
uh daniel you can refer to the page to
us
have a look at the cost of the
registration maybe
and we have different levels based on
the provisions
okay so those people who are there in
the
slack channel already i would be sharing
all these links over there and then you
can proceed further
again i'm sharing with you with my email
id if you have any doubts please mail me
at marketing either at find.bio or you
can also
mail doctor mohit at moment at the time
dot by
i hope all your questions were answered
and if not you can mail me and i'll be
there to assist you
thank you all for uh being such a
supportive audience
and if you have any doubts let me know
uh mam data science training program is
free so chitra i'll be getting uh
back to you this uh in the slack channel
itself because you are our member
already
so we can talk about this later
okay so uh actually we have uh the
members who are already a part
of the pine biotech who are already
paying for the research fellowship
program
we have a different sort of course thing
for them so i would be getting back to
it later thank you so much have a great
day
bye